[Music]
you are at fickle Creek Farm in effland
North Carolina which is in Orange County
right in the center of the pedmont
region of North Carolina and we describe
pickle Creek Farm as a small scale
Diversified sustainable farm this farm
right here is 61 Acres that's kind of
the the size of it the sustainability
part comes in with our practices we are
trying to produce food at the same time
that we protect the environment and
bring in minimal inputs from the
outside and that's always a challenge
the produce we we grow is completely by
organic standards and practices however
we've chosen to not get certified
because
sometimes the what I call technically
organic but not sustainable option just
doesn't make sense we've decided to use
locally milled feed for example the
reason for that is to get the certified
organic feed that we had available at
the time it came from a much longer
distance we sell retail direct we do
very little wholesale so it's not like
our product is on a shelf somewhere and
the only thing the consumer has to go by
is the the stamp on it that says
certified organic we're very lucky in
that we have a customer base that really
supports us they come out to the markets
and rain or shine um they appreciate
what we're doing and how we're doing it
but that helps financially of course but
that also gets us into kind of
communally sustainable the farmer and
the Farm Workers have to make a living
along the way too so it has to be
sustainable for the farmer
first this Farm is what I would call a
Agro forestry system a definition for
Agro forestry the inclusion of a Woody
perennial component in a farming system
meant to produce livestock and or
produce so our trees just like our
livestock we look at in two ways they
have service benefits and they have
product benefits so examples that we get
from the trees are
shade um improved as Aesthetics erosion
control the trees are doing doing a lot
of things that aren't necessarily
monetary income but they they are
important services to be sustainable and
to be an enjoyable place to to farm we
heat our home with firewood and so
firewood is an actual product so there
are products as well from the trees by
having not only our crops and our
pastures but then completely natural
forested areas are biodiversity is much
much higher than most agricultural
systems the livestock that we have
brought to the farm and that we have now
all got here because we were trying to
to meet a need of the farm
sustainability chickens for example we
started with laying hands and yes we
want needed the income but we also
needed the fertilizer that they were
producing and so not only did they
produce the fertilizer but they spread
it and Incorporated it for us the
chickens are really good for insect
control as well so we'll and weed seed
control all of those are again our
services
first then I think we got pigs next
their service at at the very outset was
to eradicate noxious weeds that we
couldn't get rid of any other way
because of course we don't use
herbicides and then we found out just
serendipitously that they're also great
for ra amazing Rock from pastures and
they bring them to the surface and then
we can just go out and collect them much
more readily they are great for
understory clearing so we'll take a
managed small wood lot area and we'll
put pigs in it and they'll clear it the
understory for us so then we can get in
to do the thinning that we want to do
now what we do as part of our standard
procedure is to clear a a paddock that
has um produce in it with sheep so they
eat all the vegetation the remnants of
of a crop then we bring in chickens
typically and they eat down even further
and they eat weed seeds and
scratch and then um finally we bring in
the Ducks and they just go right down
the rows just like kind of shoveling
along with their their beaks and the
Slugs are gone so and and of course
again they produce um eggs so they're
paying for
themselves we're at the very top of K
Creek Watershed which is the water for
Carbone Chapel Hill this Farm is a farm
conservation
eent and that means we sold our
development
rights um so there will never be
development on this property beyond what
is here
now you've probably heard many times
farming is really hard work and it is I
do feel like we're just one of many
farms in this area that are farming
along these lines and and we do make a
significant
impact